[ Music ]
JEAN FRANCOIS BILODEAU: Think about how
many signals your environment produces
every minute.
Sign in. End point activity.
Cloud logs.
Network events.
Now think about the attack you
don't get an alert for, the low
and slow behavior that blends
in, the suspicious patterns
that don't match a rule yet, the
early indicator that only shows
up when you connect the dots.
If you rely only on what's
already detected you risk
finding out too late when an
incident has already spread.
Let me introduce you to a
session where you'll learn how
to proactively tackle
these real world scenarios
through threat hunting
in Microsoft Sentinel.
Hello and welcome.
I'm glad you've joined us.
I'm Jean Francois Bilodeau, a
Microsoft technical trainer.
In this session we'll cover
how to perform threat hunting
in Microsoft Sentinel's
SIEM and platform.
We'll start by grounding the key
concept, what threat hunting is,
how it differs from
incident response,
and how to build a
strong hypothesis.
Then we'll move in to the
hands on hunting capabilities
in Microsoft Sentinel.
Running hunting queries.
Preserving finding
with bookmarks.
Validating activity over
time with live stream
and analyzing adversary
behavior using the MITRE
ATT&CK framework.
Finally we'll look at the tools
that help you work at scale.
Search job.
Data restoration.
Data lake.
KQL jobs. And even notebook
for advanced investigation.
So let's get started
with this session.
Let's take a look at where
this fits in your journey.
This is learning path 10, focus
on performing threat hunting
in Microsoft Sentinel across
both the SIEM experience
and the broader Sentinel
platform capabilities.
Here's what we'll cover.
First we'll explain the core
threat hunting concepts
in Microsoft Sentinel.
Then we'll walk
through how to hunt
for a threat using Sentinel
features like queries, bookmark,
live stream, and MITRE ATT&CK.
Then we'll cover how
to use search jobs
in Microsoft Sentinel.
And finally as an optional
advanced topic we'll look
at hunting for threats
using notebooks
in the Microsoft
Sentinel platform.
Let's start with
the fundamentals.
Before we run queries or build
hunting workflows it's important
to align on what threat
hunting means in practice
and how Microsoft Sentinel
supports that approach.
After completing this part
of the session you'll be
able to do two things.
First you'll be able to describe
threat hunting concepts
specifically in the context
of Microsoft Sentinel.
Second you'll be able to define
a threat hunting hypothesis
that you can use
effectively in Sentinel.
Here we define what we mean by
cybersecurity threat hunting.
Different teams define threat
huntings in different ways,
but the most common and
useful definition is this.
You are proactively searching
through your environment
for a threat or a
set of activities
that you have not
previously detected.
That phrase not previously
detected is the key point.
This is what separates threat
hunting from incident response
or alert triage which starts
from something that's
already been flagged.
Threat hunting is
meant to be continual.
You ask good questions.
You search for evidence.
You learn from what you find.
And you repeat the cycle
to steadily reduce
attacker (inaudible) time.
Now let's talk about building
a threat hunting hypothesis
because good hunting starts
with a good hypothesis.
First keep it achievable.
If it's too ambitious
it won't get finished.
Second keep the scope narrow so
you can validate or disprove it
with the data you have.
Third keep it time bound.
Define a clear window like the
last 24 hours, the last 7 days,
or a specific time
frame around an event.
Fourth keep it
useful and efficient
so the work produces actionable
insights rather than just noise.
And fifth keep it related to the
threat model you're defending
against so your hunting effort
is aligned to the adversaries
and techniques that matter
most to your organization.
With those concepts in mind,
let's move in to how Microsoft
Sentinel supports threat hunting
from the moment
you start querying
to the way you capture findings,
monitor for recurrence,
and map behavior to
common adversary tactics.
By the end of this part you'll
be able to use queries to hunt
for threats, save key findings
using bookmarks, observe threats
over time using live stream, and
use the MITRE ATT&CK framework
for threat vector analysis.
Here we focus on threat
hunting queries.
In Microsoft Sentinel you can
capture and run hunting queries
to search for isolated security
threats and unwanted activity,
especially the kind of signals
that haven't generated alerts.
The idea is to iteratively ask
a question, query the data,
refine your logic, and then
pivot based on what you discover
until you either confirm
your suspicious behavior
or build confidence that
the activity is benign.
As you hunt you want a clean way
to capture the
evidence you found.
Bookmarks in Microsoft
Sentinel help you do exactly
that by preserving the query you
ran along with the query result
that you consider relevant.
This makes it easier to
return to your work later,
share findings with your
teammates, and build continuity
between threat hunting and
incident investigation.
Next let's take a
look at live stream.
Sometimes you don't just
want to look backward.
You want to validate
a hypothesis
against live activity.
The hunting live stream lets
you test queries against events
as they occur in an
interactive session.
You can also configure
notifications so that
when Sentinel finds events
matching your query you're
alerted in near real time.
Now let's connect what we
find to a common language
for adversary behavior
using MITRE ATT&CK.
In Microsoft Sentinel the attack
matrix helps you analyze threat
vector using
tactics, techniques,
and procedures
often called TTPs.
As you explore the matrix
the legend colors correspond
to detection making it
easier to understand
where you have coverage, where
your detection are firing,
and where you may need to
improve visibility or analytics.
With your core hunting workflow
established let's shift
to capabilities that help you
work with larger time range
and different data tier: search
jobs, restoring historical data,
and creating data lake KQL job
in the Microsoft
Sentinel platform.
After completing this module
you'll be able to hunt
with a search job in
Microsoft Sentinel,
restore historical data
in Microsoft Sentinel,
and create data lake KQL
job in Microsoft Sentinel.
Here we introduce search
job where you need to hunt
across larger data sets
or longer time horizons.
A search job lets you run your
hunt in a way that's optimized
for that scenario in
the data lake search
and restore experience.
You define what you're looking
for, kick off the search job,
and then review the result
when the job completes
making it practical
to investigate patterns
that would be cumbersome
to query interactively.
Now let's take a look at
restoring historical data.
There are times where you need
older information available
for deeper investigation.
Maybe you're validating
when suspicious
activity first appears.
Or you're correlating today's
signal with something
that happened months ago.
The data restoration capability
helps you bring historical data
back in to an accessible state
so you can query it as part
of your hunting and
investigation workflow.
Let's focus on
data lake KQL job.
This capability is designed
for running KQL at scale
against data lake source helping
you operationalize repeatable
hunt or large analytical
queries without relying solely
on interactive exploration.
You define the job, run it, and
then work it with the output
to continue your investigation
or support broader analytics.
Now let's move in to an
optional, but powerful set
of capabilities using
notebooks for threat hunting.
In Microsoft Sentinel
notebooks open the door
to an advanced investigation
workflow enrichment,
visualization, and even
machine learning approaches.
As you complete this
module you'll be able
to explore API library for
advanced threat hunting
in Microsoft Sentinel, describe
what notebooks are in sentinel,
create and use notebooks in
Microsoft Sentinel, and create
and use notebooks in the
Microsoft Sentinel data lake.
Let's clarify where notebooks
fit by comparing them
to playbook and workbook.
Playbooks are primarily
for automation often used
by SOC engineers and analysts to
handle simpler repeatable tasks
like bringing in external
data, enriching alert
with threat intelligence, or
GeoIP supporting investigation
and performing
remediation steps.
Workbooks focus
on visualization,
serving SOC engineers,
analysts, and SOC managers
who need dashboard and
view over their data.
Notebooks on the other hand are
designed for deeper analysis
and flexible investigation.
They're commonly used by
threat hunters and tier two
and three analysts,
incident investigators,
cyber data scientists,
and security researchers.
With notebooks you can
query Microsoft Sentinel
and external data sources,
enrich your findings with look
up like threat intelligence,
GeoIP, or Whois,
support investigations,
build visualization,
run structured hunts, and
even apply machine learning
and big data analytics.
If you want to go
deeper you can look
up the becoming a Microsoft
Sentinel notebook ninja series
on the Microsoft
tech community site.
Here we zoom out and look
at how Microsoft Sentinel data
can be accessed beyond the
portal experience.
The foundation of
Microsoft Sentinel is
to log analytic data stored
which supports high performance
querying, a dynamic schema,
and the ability to scale
to massive data volume.
The Azure portal and Sentinel
tooling uses a standard API
to access that store.
And that same API is also
available for external tools
like Python and PowerShell.
To simplify access there
are several libraries
and resources you can leverage.
KQLmagic provides an easy
to implement wrapper
for running KQL query, MSTICPy.
Microsoft's threat intelligence
Python security tool offers a
rich set of Python
tools intended
for security investigation
and hunting.
You can also explore the
Sentinel community GitHub
resource including the Azure
Azure dash Sentinel dash
notebook repository on GitHub
which contains interactive
notebooks designed
to provide security
insight and actions
for investigating anomalies and
hunting for malicious behavior.
And of course you can
use the API directly
through Jupyter Notebook and
other Python based workflows.
Now let's talk about
creation options.
You have two
straightforward paths.
First you can create
a notebook directly
from the Microsoft
Sentinel notebooks page.
Second you can create a Jupyter
Notebook using external tools
such as Visual Studio
Code and then connect it
to your Sentinel workflow.
Here we look at what notebook
works actually feels like.
The code block from the
getting started guide
from Microsoft Sentinel
ML notebooks provides a
representative
example of working
with Microsoft Sentinel data
showing how you can pull data,
shape it, and analyze it
in an iterative investigation
friendly workflow
Next let's take a look
at data lake notebooks
and the Microsoft
Sentinel platform.
A key take away here is that
you use the Microsoft Sentinel
Visual Studio Code extension
and the NCP model context
protocol server directly
in the notebook enabling a
more integrated experience
for data exploration and hunting
against those data lake sources.
Here we walk through
Visual Studio Code
for notebook including
GitHub Copilot,
the Microsoft Sentinel MCP
server, and the Sentinel Python
and Jupyter extension.
Start by selecting the
Visual Studio Code icon
from the task bar.
Quick note.
Unless specified otherwise,
always install the Microsoft
published extension.
From the left menu
open extension.
Then search for Python
and select install.
Next search for Jupyter
Notebook and install it
if it's not already installed.
Then search for GitHub
Copilot and install it.
Finally search for Microsoft
Sentinel and install
that extension as well.
Now open the command palette
by pressing control shift
P. Find and select MCP.
Add server.
Choose the HTTP option and enter
the URL sentinel.microsoft.com
/mcp/data-exploration.
Accept the default server
ID then authenticate
when prompted by
selecting allow.
From the account type choose
work or school account assigned
to your organization
and select continue.
When prompted, enter
the credential provided
for by your organization.
Approve the access by
selecting yes all app,
and then your device
is registered.
Select done to
complete the setup.
Now it's time to bring it all
together with a demonstration
of performing threat hunting
in Microsoft Sentinel
applying the concepts
and tools we've discussed
to proactively search
for suspicious activity and
capture actionable findings.
In this demo let's start doing
some hunting using Sentinel.
We'll begin by running
a query to look
for suspicious
PowerShell activity
in our security event table.
Let's drop in a query, run it,
and we can see we are getting
some suspicious activity
through PowerShell, especially
this last line over here,
PowerShell, where we can see
it's running this script
that I'm not familiar with so
over here let's investigate
that in more detail.
Let's start our hunt.
The first thing I want
to do here is I want
to add a bookmark.
That row here is of interest.
Let's select it.
Add bookmark.
And there we go.
We've bookmarked that entry.
Now because there's a host
in that entry let's map
that to our entity.
As we do our hunting we'll know
which computer is involved.
This will help us
with entity analysis.
We'll also mark
this as a command
and control MITRE techniques.
Create. And there go.
We've created our
first bookmark.
We're starting to gather
intelligence with this hunt.
Let's go back to hunting.
Let's go to our queries.
And let's create a new
hunting query based
on what we've discovered.
Let's create a
PowerShell hunt query.
Here's the same query
we were using earlier.
And we're going to do the same
mapping that we did previously.
You have the host.
Let's map that to the computer.
Host name.
And that's the computer.
And tactic.
Let's use the same one.
Command and control.
Create. And now we
can run the query.
Here's our details.
Right click.
Run. And now we can see that
we're running one query
and we're getting three results.
There's the three results.
It's showing up three
times on our screen.
Let's add that to a live
stream so we can keep an eye
on what's happening with
our shell execution.
Let's run a live stream.
We're still at three result.
One query is running.
Let's go back to the evidence we
captured earlier to bookmark.
We'll click on bookmarks.
Let's crack it open.
There's the detail that
we've captured earlier.
And let's start
our investigation.
Because we mapped an
entity now I have access
to the entity graph which I
can use now to drill deeper
and cooperate with other
signal, other telemetry logs
that we've received in
our events in Sentinel.
I'm not going to delve any
deeper inside our entity graph,
but I want to show you
how by mapping entities
to the result it provides
that entity graph.
For our next demo
let's use notebooks
and a bit of machine learning.
To help with that, let's
crack open our notebooks
and let's configure an Azure
machine learning workspace.
We'll select our resource group.
We want to create the workspace.
Let's give it a distinct name.
We'll put it in west US two.
And we can leave the rest as is.
Let's just jump to
review of plus create.
Launch the creation.
And there we go.
We've got our machine
learning workspace created.
Let's go back to our workbook
and let's pick up
a great starter.
Let's use the getting
started guide
for Microsoft Sentinel
machine learning notebook.
Let's create the
notebook from here.
We'll link it to the machine
learning workspace we created
just a moment ago.
And there go.
We've made a copy
of the template.
We're ready to launch it.
This will bring us to Microsoft
Foundry Azure machine learning.
Let's create a compute cluster.
I'll create a quick
one over here.
Let's give it a name.
Just call it hunting ML.
We'll leave the rest as is.
Review plus create.
And let's launch the creation.
Next we've got our cluster,
but let's make sure
we select Python.
We're going to use
PyTorch and TensorFlow
to do our machine learning.
The notebook is already created
and it's already
executed for us.
A notebook is a collection of
text and code like this block
that we're seeing over here.
Some Python code in this
case that we're executing.
More code that we're executing.
The first two examples are
pretty straightforward.
Now we're getting in to actual
machine learning code itself.
We're not going to
spend time on the code,
but this is a great learning
resource for the analyst
that wants to seriously get
in to machine learning.
Let's restart the workbook
from the beginning.
We're going to
reexecute everything.
And we'll start with
that block over here
where we add up 2 plus 2.
Moving down we're going to
take a look at MSTICPy.
This is where we're getting
in to the more interesting
machine learning task.
We're going to
reset it once more.
Let's scroll down and now we can
execute individual tasks one
by one should we choose to.
Let's pick the next (inaudible).
Let's go to that task over here.
Here's the run button.
So let's just run that one
task, that one code block.
Here is the output.
Again we're not going to worry
too much about the code,
but we can see that it was
able to invoke Python.
It was able to invoke MSTICPy.
Everything worked correctly.
We're okay across the board.
This is not really a hunting
notebook, but it's a great place
to start for those of us who are
interested in getting deeper
in to automation, getting
in to machine learning,
getting in to Python.
There's plenty more
notebooks to explore.
Have fun. Let's recap
what you've learned
in this learning path.
First threat hunting.
You learned how to perform
threat hunting using Microsoft
Sentinel using
queries, bookmarks,
live stream, and MITRE ATT&CK.
Next hunting tools.
You explored ways to extend
your hunting with notebooks,
search jobs, and external tools.
And finally threat
hunting hypotheses.
You've learned how to develop a
hypothesis that's achievable,
narrow in scope, time bound,
useful, and efficient,
and aligned with the threat
model you're defending against.
Thank you for participating
in this Microsoft security
operation analyst course.
I hope you enjoyed learning
about Microsoft security as much
as I enjoyed presenting the
concept and walking you
through the live demos.
I encourage you
to remain curious
and continue exploring
new capabilities.
That's how you'll keep
staying relevant.
When you're ready
I encourage you
to take the SC 200
certification exam.
There are many ways to continue
your learning journey.
I invite you to search for
your next favorite topic
on Microsoft Learn
at aka.ms/learn.